Nhanh y tế hà lội quyến cáo người dân bình tính không hoang mang nhưng cũng không lời là chức biến thế mới bèa bà trấm 2 của vi đu rác COVID-2.
Đông thời tiếp tục truyết chỉ các biển pháp phòng chống dịch trong cuộc đồng.
Sở y tế hà lội cho biết đến nay chưa có bằng chứng cho thấy biến thế bèa bà trấm 2.
Về bệnh nạ hơn, sau với các biến thế trước, tuy nhiên vi đu rác COVID-2 vẫn đàn liều hành.
Bây màn, we call suy hiện thêm các biến thế mới.
Nhất là tại những người đông người, môi trường kiến như trường học, có sự y tế.
Này nghĩ thế hà lội quyến cáo người dân tiếp tục từ kiện các biển pháp phòng người bệnh như đeo của trang tại người con cân.
Cứ sự y tế, thương suyên trở tài cửa của mình mặt tiếp xúc như tay năm kỳ và làm việc đyện thoại và các tiếp bị cá nhân.
Chua đón theo rồi xức quẻ, hàn chế tiếp xúc của người khác thì có biểu hiện như sốt, vì đường hấp, chương hợp bánh nhẹ người dân chỉ cần gì ngơi bộ xung nước và điều chỉ trở chuyển thông dân hộ cám của y tế.
Khi xuất hiện các giấu hiệu nặng như su cào hóa thờ đông người.
Nơi dân cần đến hệ mấy cơ sở ý tế để được thăm khám đều chỉ kì thôi.
Theo chúng tâm kiểm soát bệnh xe đi xe thành phó hà nội, từ ngày hát mươi tháng 3 đến hệ tháng 3,
hệ thống giám 3 mệnh chuẩn giận giận mấy bệnh các mắt của viết mình chiến tại mấy 2 phường giả.
Tổn chức đó hà nội viện nhận 3 cơ viết mình chiến tại 3 cường giả.
Tính từ đầu năm hành hủ xong hệ sau đến nay, hà nội gì nhận 3 mi chính trở mắt của viết mình chiến tại 2 mi 2 sả thường không có cơ tử vong.
Tăng năm ca mắt sau với cuộc kỳ hành hủ xong hệ lắm.
Các chuyên gia nhận định, sự suy hiện của các biến thệ mới là khu lật tế hoa tự nhiên của virus.
Vó đó không chuyện chỉ thể thống giám 3 tế và nân cao ý thức phòng bệnh trong cộng đồng.